♪ ♪
>> Tammy: WELCOME A TWITTER
SURE HAS SHOWN US THAT THEY HAVE
A QUICK TRIGGER WHEN IT COMES TO
CENSORING CONSERVATIVES.
THE TECH GIANT DECIDED TO LET IT
TREND FOR LIKE 11 HOURS BEFORE
TAKING ACTION.
THE ONSLAUGHT OF HATE CAME AFTER
TIM SCOTT ARGUED IN A REBUTTAL
TO BIDEN THAT AMERICA IS NOT A
RACIST COUNTRY.
WHAT A CONCEPT.
IT MAY HAVE BEEN WHY THEY LET IT
SLIDE FOR SO LONG.
GOOD LUCK TO GEORGIA.
THAT SOUNDS FABULOUS.
YOU ARE RUNNING, SIR, AS A
REPUBLICAN.
THANK YOU FOR JOINING ME
TONIGHT.
>> THANK YOU SO MUCH.
I'M HONORED TO BE HERE.
I AM HERE IN CARTERSVILLE,
GEORGIA, WHICH IS A GREAT
COMMUNITY.
WE HAVE ALL THESE FOLKS IN
GEORGIA.
LOOKING FORWARD TO THIS UPCOMING
ELECTION.
IT IS A RED STATE, NOT A BLUE
STATE.
JUST LIKE A LOT OF THE OTHERS,
YOU MENTIONED SOMETHING EARLIER.
THERE IS RACISM.
IF THERE WERE NOT, THE DEMOCRATS
WOULD NOT BE CALLING HIM A
COCOON AND ALL THOSE OTHER
NAMES.
SO THE REAL RACISM IS IN THE
DEMOCRATIC PARTY THAT IS LED BY
NO OTHER THAN JOE BIDEN.
LET'S BE CLEAR ABOUT ONE THING.
LIBERALS ARE HORRIFIED BY OTHERS
WHO ARE INDEPENDENT.
THIS IS A TACTIC TO DESTROY THEM
AND TO RUN THEM BACK ON THE
PLANTATION.
WE ARE HERE AND WE ARE HERE TO
STAY.
WE WANT TO PUT AMERICA FIRST AND
TO SUPPORT THE LEGACY OF
DONALD TRUMP HERE WE ARE GOING
TO CONTINUE TO TAKE THIS FIGHT
TO THE LEFT.
THEY CAN'T PLAY THAT RACE CARD
ON ME.
THEY ARE THE RACISTS AND YOU
KNOW THAT, TAMMY.
WE ARE GOING TO TAKE THE FIGHT
DIRECTLY TO THEM.
>> Tammy: WELL THAT'S VERY
EXCITING.
OBVIOUSLY, YOU KNOW, A LOT OF US
TALK ABOUT HOW TO MAKE A
DIFFERENCE AND THEN THERE ARE
THOSE OF YOU WHO STAND UP AND
PUT YOURSELF IN FRONT.
BUT IT IS ESPECIALLY AS
MINORITIES.
A LOT OF PEOPLE DON'T KNOW I'M A
GAY WOMAN AND THERE IS A DYNAMIC
WHERE THERE IS THIS PRESUMPTION
THAT YOU ARE OWNED BY A CERTAIN
SECTION OF POLITICS AND THAT IF
YOU DO NOT CONFORM, YOU WILL BE
PUNISHED.
IT IS OBSCENE.
IT IS WHAT WE FOUGHT A CIVIL WAR
OVER TO ESCAPE, TO GET OUT OF.
AND THIS IS WHAT, IT IS VERY
POWERFUL FOR AMERICANS TO SEE
AND EVERYONE TO SEE.
THESE MINORITIES WHO ARE
AFFECTED FIRST BY ECONOMIC
CHANGE, WHO BENEFIT FROM IT MOST
WHEN IT'S GOOD, AS UNDER
PRESIDENT TRUMP, AND THEN WHO
ARE HURT BY IT THE MOST WHEN IT
COMES DRIVEN BY A JIMMY CARTER
OR JOE BIDEN.
THIS IS THE OWNERSHIP OF WHAT
HAS TO HAPPEN AND TO HAVE VOICES
SPEAK ABOUT THE DIFFERENCE.
BUT WHEN IT COMES TO SOMEONE
LIKE TIM SCOTT, THEY CLEARLY
SEEM TO BE FRIGHTENED BY HIM.
THEY ARE FRIGHTENED BY YOU,
BECAUSE THE SINGLE VOICE THAT
STEPS UP CAN MAKE A HUGE
DIFFERENCE.
AND WE CAN POINT OUT WHAT THIS
MEANS.
DO YOU THINK THAT WHEN IT COMES
TO CERTAINLY PEOPLE ON THE LEFT
AND PEOPLE IN GEORGIA AS AN
EXAMPLE, WILL THEY BE CONVINCED
THAT PEOPLE WHO ARE
CONSERVATIVE, AFRICAN-AMERICANS
ARE TO BE WARY OF THEM?
HOW DO YOU THINK THIS IS BEING
REGISTERED AMONGST OTHER
AMERICANS, THIS RHETORIC FROM
THE DEMOCRATS?
>> WELL, LET ME TELL YOU,
DONALD TRUMP HAS A GOOD
PLAYBOOK.
HE SAID WHAT DO YOU HAVE TO LOSE
WHILE IN THE OTHER HAND, HE SAID
IF YOU VOTE REPUBLICAN, THERE
WERE TO PUT YOU BACK IN CHAINS.
I AM REMINDED OF
"THE WIZARD OF OZ."
ONE HAS NO BRAIN.
THE OTHER HAS NO COURAGE.
AND THE OTHER HAS NO --
WHAT.
YOU KNOW WHAT I'M SAYING.
AND SO, WHEN I ALSO THINK ABOUT
THEM, THEY ARE NOT BEING LED BY
DOROTHY.
THEY ARE BEING LED BY, WHAT, THE
WICKED WITCH, STACEY ABRAMS.
SHE IS BEING PAID AND THEN
HUSTLED TO KEEP BLACKS THINKING
THEY ARE DEPRESSED DONE MICHAEL
OPPRESSED AND VICTIMS.
WHO IS FRONTING THIS?
THE LIBERALS.
THEY DON'T WANT BLACK PEOPLE TO
THINK THEY CAN EVEN AFFORD AN
I.D.
YOU NEED WANT TO CHECK INTO A
HOTEL.
IT'S JUST CRAZY.
I'M HERE TONIGHT.
I MENTIONED WITH THE FAMILY.
THEY DON'T CARE ABOUT THAT.
BUT THE LEFT IS AFRAID THAT
BLACK PEOPLE, THEY ARE SAYING
WAIT A MINUTE, THE
DEMOCRATIC PARTY HAS LET US OFF
A CLIFF.
>> Tammy: WHEREVER WE LOOKED,
WHETHER IT'S LOS ANGELES,
SAN FRANCISCO, DETROIT,
BALTIMORE, GREAT AMERICAN
CITIES, NEW YORK, ATLANTA, THAT
THINGS HAVE NOT GOTTEN BETTER IN
THE URBAN AREAS.
WHEREVER THE DEMOCRATS ARE IN
CONTROL, THERE IS THE STATUS QUO
OF MISERY.
IT IS THE 21ST CENTURY.
EVERYONE DESERVES BETTER.
THIS COUNTRY WILL ONLY GET
BETTER WHEN THE LIVES OF PEOPLE
ON THE MARGINS AND PEOPLE OF
COLOR, PEOPLE WHO ARE MINORITIES
GET BETTER.
AND THE DEMOCRATS HAVE CONVINCED
MANY PEOPLE THAT THERE IS ONLY
ONE PLACE TO GO.
I BELIEVE THAT WITH YOU, SIR,
AND PEOPLE LIKE DONALD TRUMP,
WHO CLEARLY IS NOT GOING AWAY,
THAT WE WILL MAKE SURE THAT WE
KNOW THERE ARE ALTERNATIVES AND
AN IMPORTANT MOVE FORWARD.
THANK YOU FOR BEING HERE
TONIGHT.
I REALLY APPRECIATE IT.
VERY IMPORTANT TIME.